we've learned a little bit about gravity
we've learned a little bit about
electrostatics Oh time to learn about a
new fundamental force of the universe
and this one is probably second most
familiar to us next to gravity and
that's magnetism magnetism where does
the word come from well they actually I
think several civilizations I'm no
historian found these lodestones these
objects magnetism magnetism these
objects that would attract other objects
like at other magnets or would even
attract metallic objects like iron
ferrous objects and they're called
lodestones that's I guess the Western
term for it and the reason why they're
called magnets is because they're named
after lodestones that were found near
the Greek province of magnesia magnesia
and actually think the people who lived
there were called magnets but anyway
let's let you could Wikipedia that and
learn more about it than I know but
anyway let's let's focus on what
magnetism is and I think most of us have
at least a working knowledge of what it
is in terms you know we've all played
with magnets and we've dealt with
compasses but I'll tell you this right
now what it really is is pretty deep and
I think it's fairly I don't think anyone
has we can mathematically understand it
and manipulate it and see how it relates
to electricity we actually will show you
that the electrostatic force and the
magnetic force are actually the same
thing just viewed from different frames
of references I know all of that sounds
very complicated all of that but in our
classical Newtonian world we treat them
as two different forces but what I'm
saying is although we're kind of used to
a magnet just like we're used to gravity
just like gravity is also fairly
mysterious when you really think about
what it is
so is magnetism so with that said let's
listen please try to get some working
knowledge of how we can deal with
magnetism so we're all familiar with a
magnet
want it to be yellow I can make the
boundary yellow no I didn't want it to
be like that either so if this is a
magnet we know that a magnet always has
two poles it has a North Pole and a
South Pole and these were just labeled
by convention because when people first
discovered these lodestones or they took
a lodestone and they magnetized a needle
with with that lodestone and then that
needle they put on a cork in a bucket of
water and that needle would point to the
Earth's North Pole they said oh well the
point the side of the needle that is
pointing to the Earth's north let's call
that the North Pole and the point of the
needle that's pointing to the South Pole
the sorry the point of the needle that's
pointing to the Earth's geographic South
we'll call that the South Pole or
another way to put it if we have a
magnet the direction of the magnet or
the side of the magnet that Orient's
itself it's allowed to orient freely
without friction towards our geographic
north we call that the North Pole and
the other side is the South Pole and
this is actually a little bit if you
know obviously we call the we call the
earth we call the top of the earth the
North Pole you know this is the North
Pole north pole and we call this the
South Pole and magnet and there's
another notion of magnetic north and
that's where I guess you could kind of
say that is where a a a a compass the
north point of a compass will point to
an actually magnetic north it moves
around because we have all of this
moving fluid inside of the earth and a
bunch of other interactions it's a very
complex interaction but magnetic north
is actually roughly in northern Canada
so magnetic north might be here so that
might be magnetic north and magnetic
south I don't know exactly where that is
but it can kind of move around a little
bit it's not in the same place so it's a
little bit off the axes of the
geographic North Pole and the South Pole
and this is another kind of slightly
confusing thing is magnetic north is
kind of the geographical
pation we're a north where the north
pole of a magnet will point to but that
would actually be the South Pole of if
you viewed the earth as a magnetic as a
magnet so if this was if the earth was a
big magnet this would you'd actually
view that as the South Pole of the
magnet and this and the geographic South
Pole is the North Pole of the magnet you
could read more about that on Wikipedia
no it's a little bit confusing but in
general when most people refer to
magnetic north or the North Pole they're
talking about the geographic north area
and the South Pole is a geographic South
area but the reason why I make this
distinction is because we know when we
deal with magnets just like electricity
although or electrostatics but although
we'll show it of key difference very
shortly is that opposite poles attract
so if this side of my magnet is
attracted to Earth's North Pole then
Earth's North Pole or Earth's magnetic
north actually must be the South Pole of
that magnet right and vice-versa the
South Pole of my magnet here is going to
be attracted to Earth's magnetic south
which is actually the North Pole of the
magnet we call Earth anyway I'll take
Earth out of the equation because it
takes a little bit confusing and we'll
just stick to bars because that tends to
be a little bit more consistent let me
erase this let me there you go
I'll erase my magnesia I wonder if the
element magnesium was first discovered
in magnesia as well probably and I
actually looked up milk of magnesia
which is a laxative and it was not
discovered in magnesia but it has
magnesium in it so I guess it's roots
could be in magnesia if magnesium was
discovered in magnesia anyway enough
about magnesia back to the magnets so if
this is a magnet and let me draw another
magnet actually let me erase all of this
when I go on the tangents I just
all right so let me draw two more
magnets
that's one magnet that's another magnet
we know from experimentation when we
were all kids this is the North Pole
this is the South Pole that the North
Pole is going to be attracted to the
South Pole of another magnet and then if
I were to flip this magnet around it
would actually repel north to North
facing magnets would repel each other
and so we have this notion just like we
had in electrostatics that a magnet
generates a field it generates this
these vectors around it that if you put
something in that field that will that
can be affected by it it'll be it'll be
so there will be some net force acting
on it so actually before I go into the
magnetic field actually want to make one
huge distinction between a magnet and or
between magnetism and electrostatics
magnetism always comes in the form of a
dipole what does the dipole mean it
means that we have two poles a north and
a south and electrostatics you do have
two two charges you have a positive
charge and a negative charge so you do
have two charges but they could be by
themselves you could just have a proton
you don't have to have an electron
they're right next to it you could just
have a proton and it would create a
positive electrostatic field right in
our field lines or what a positive point
charge would do and it would be repelled
so you don't always have to have an
electronegative charge there similarly
you could just have an electron and you
don't have to have a proton there so you
could have mono poles these are called
mono poles when you just have one charge
when you're talking about electrostatics
but with magnetism you always have a
dipole if I were to take this magnet
this one right here and if I were to cut
it in half if I were to cut it in half
somehow miraculously each of those
halves of that magnet will turn into two
more magnets where this will be the
south this will be the north this will
be the south and this
we'll be the north and actually the
theoretically I've read my my own
abilities don't go this far there could
be such a thing as a magnetic monopole
although it has not been observed yet in
nature but so everything we have seen in
nature has been a dipole so you can just
keep cutting this cutting this up all
the way down to if it's just one
electron left and it actually turns out
that even one electron is still a
magnetic dipole it still is generating
it still has a North Pole and a South
Pole and actually turns out all magnets
there the magnetic field is actually
generated by the electrons within it by
the spin of the electrons and that you
know when we talk about electron spin we
imagine you know some little ball of
charge that's spinning but electrons are
you know it's hard to they do have mass
but it it starts to get fuzzy whether
they're energy or mass and then how does
it ball of energy spin etc so it gets
very contem very almost metaphysical so
I don't want to go too far into it and I
frankly I don't think you really can't
get an intuition it is almost you know
it is a realm that we don't normally
operate in but even these large magnets
you deal with the magnetic field is
generated by the electron spins inside
of it and by the actual magnetic fields
generated by the electron motion around
the protons well I hope hope I'm not not
not overwhelming you and you might say
well how come sometimes a metal bar can
be magnetized in hot sighs sometimes it
won't be well when a when all of the
electrons are doing random different
things in a metal bar then it's not
magnetized because they're the magnetic
spins or the magnet the the magnetism
created by the electrons are all
cancelling each other out because it's
random but if you align the spins of the
electrons and if you're aligned their
rotations then of then you will have a
magnetically charged bar if anyway I'm
past the 10-minute mark
but hopefully that gives you a little
bit of a working knowledge of what a
magnet is and in the next video I will
show what the effect is well one I'll
I'll explain how we think about a
magnetic field and then what the effect
of a magnetic field is on an electron or
not even electric on a moving charge see
in the next video